and Merlin the biggest challenge was
that it was in the toughest industry
which is hyper security cybersecurity is
a very complex space to begin with it's
a very very established industry so
coming into the space where the
disruptive mind is a unique challenge in
itself we wanted to make sure that the
cloud technology we choose is native and
native cloud technologies are very hard
to build in a private cloud environment
and that's where kubernetes and
containers and the IBM cloud environment
became really important so choosing a
loosely coupled architecture and
choosing IBM cloud private and IBM
strains it allowed us to ensure that
these processes can run in any cloud the
garage was able to provide us the skills
that were needed for those technologies
which was huge because many times when
we choose the technology we just don't
have the skills in-house the IBM garage
gave us the methodology and it also
allowed everyone to think like a product
owner so what the garage allows everyone
to do is come into an ecosystem where
you enhance your own capabilities but
you follow a process which is very
nimble we've established a very strong
product and going forward all we have to
do is scale it to an enterprise scale
and we can onboard many many new
features and technologies like AI like
machine learning we can grow with
partnerships we are already working with
a lot of companies today who want to
onboard their solutions on our platform
because we are extensible
you